it wasn't tense like my palms were
sweating because I was like really
trying to get through it super pumped no
I really like calm down
I loved it was really great I love like
action in it when I wasn't shooting the
ceiling I wasn't shooting my foot I was
doing it right yeah this is the first
time I ever touched
Rainbow six any of that and it was fun I
got to see the trailer for it everything
at e3 but finally getting to get my
hands on it I love the gameplay I
remember playing the first one back way
back and just it's the same core element
but it just feels more frantic and
connected with your teammates and
everything it's just so much more fun
when you're talking to each other versus
being muted and trying to execute one
objective I was so drawn into it so
sucked it a little disappointed that my
wife was able to survive and I died you
know being able to communicate where
where people are where things are being
observed and being hyper-vigilant this
game sort of teaches you that I liked I
liked how I was able to like choose a
cool character I really loved the
battering ram so bad the battering
hammer split is pretty amazing yeah if
you use it the right way
alright is the controller actually
really easy to like use and the rules
really simple they really fund able to
get into and start doing action I think
you guys got it down I mean this game
has gonna come out yet it seems pretty
perfect to me it's definitely an
actually thing it ended up being so much
fun I'm so glad this is the first game I
got into like this is this is definitely
it like she said she got sucked in and
she's really uh I think she's gonna
actually play with me hi I was looking
at red alandrach